あの気楽に座って気楽に聞いてください
でないとわからなくなります
で これすごい古いところから取った場所で
ジャータカの百じゃなくて
一番最後のところ 八大地獄
地獄は八あります サンジーボーカーレスットーチェサンガートーデーチェロールはアターパローマハヴィチーターペノーチェパターペノーということで覚えておけば八
もわかります
一番目はサンジーボという地獄です
二番目はカーラスットートゥナサンガートー四ロールを四ロールを三番目
五番目はマハーロールを
六番目はマハーヴィチーターペノーパターペノー
という八大地獄があるんです
もう日本訳なんかわかりません
日本でよく聞いているのは六番目にあるマハーアヴィーチですね
アジビ地獄とかよく聞かれたことはあります
まあ説明もできない もう難しいし
別にややこしいしね はい
次に行きます それから像地獄あるいは小地獄は十六あります
各大地獄は十六の像 像地獄で囲まれている
なんか地獄っていうのは逃げられないように
なんかすごい山々みたいな
十六に囲まってるみたいです
だから 地獄が逃げたければ
もう山を四つ越えなくちゃいけない
それも地獄なんですね
それで全部百三十六地獄があるんです
経典にさらにローカンテリカという地獄の名前も出てきます
我々の太陽系と関係なく
宇宙にある太陽の光さえも届かないところだそうで
そういう説明なんです
それもお釈迦様の説明なんです
もう極端にもう太陽の光も何も届かない
宇宙の間にあるんだよと
ローカンテリカというローカのアンテリカ
インビトゥイーンということで
間ですね 経典 注釈 仏典などの地獄の説明は複雑になっています
結構複雑で 地獄の話を言うと
なんか嫌がるんですよ
あまり仏教は言えない
私は本堂の方にいましたけど
そちらにこの天台宗の宗旨ということを書いてあって
それを読んでいたんです
で みんな本来は仏性を持ってるんだと
で いろいろな迷いがあって
もうそれでいろんな念が起きて苦しんでるんだと
そういうふうにやると
みんなすごいいい気分になるんですよ
心が明るくなるんです
一応 私は本来仏性あると言わないんだけど
一応明るい方向へ語るのが仏教の世界なんです
脅しはしない ですから
この どうしようもない時だけ言うんですね
ですから お釈迦様もちゃんと地獄が八があって
これでこれは これはこれで
そういう説明してないんです
一応 あの偈はジャータカパーリから取ったし
もう全仏教各宗派でどこでもこれはもう一応設定しているんだから
もうもともとの考え方っていうことはすごい確かなんですね
うん でお釈迦様はどちらかというと
もう随分いろんな名前で
その時その時地獄のことを言う
で 経典はそこ 注釈者はそれを拒否するんです
一つの地獄がありまして
なんて名前でしたっけ？なんかエーカンタアーヤタナドッカなんとかっていう名前で
やはり定かないんで ちょっと覚えて思い出しませんだけど
六上が極端に苦の地獄があるんだよと
で 六処っていうのは眼耳鼻舌身意なんですよ
それで説明します お釈迦様は
その人々は見るものは全部極端に苦しみを作るんだと
一欠片も楽しみはないんだと
聞くものは何だかんで耳に入る音はものすごい苦しみを作るんだと
嗅ぐものも 味わうものも
体に触れるものも 徹底的に極端に苦のみであると
それで考える思考も極端に苦のみ作るんだと
そういうところもあるんだよと
注釈書を見てみたら そんな地獄はないんだと
それはアディグ地獄のこと
アチアヴィーチ地獄のことをお釈迦様は説明してるんだと
そんな権限 注釈書にはないと思いますけど
一応お釈迦様はある場所のことを言ってるわけじゃなくて
心理的に心理学的にこの苦しみを説明してるんですよ
本当は お釈迦様は理性
形而上学的なところには飛ばない
飛ばないんです だからいろいろだから説明難しい
もう調べればいくらでも経典に出てきますけど
これとあれはどうやって合わせればいいかとかわからなくなるんですね
はい 次に行きます 一応はぐらい地獄あるんだと
で 仏説から地獄のへの招待紹介
マジュリニカイのバーラパンディタスッタという経典がありまして
あの まあ読める方々は読んでみてもよろしいし
かなり地獄の苦しみを明確に説明しています
こちらもちょこっと説明はします
ニラヤメワタンサンマワダマノワデイヤエーカンタンアニッタン
エーカンタンアカンタン
エーカンタンアマナーパンティ
ニラヤというのは地獄というのは正しく言うならば
それはエーカンタンアニッタン
もうとんでもない 極端ですよ
極端にもう不幸な これは辞書を引いて単語を入れただけなんです
一番目はアニッタンというのは良いところは一つもない
もう気持ち悪い エーカンタンアカンタンっていうのはまた同じで
もういいことっていうのはひとかけらもないと
極端に不快な エーカンタンアマナータン
極端に不快な 自分の希望どおりに一つもいかないんですよ
だからこの自由意識は完全停止ですよ
地獄に落ちたら餓鬼道と違う
すごい怖いところ たとえで説明することも難しいんですと釈尊が言うんですよ
釈尊というのは 人類の中で言葉はもう釈尊ほど使いません
誰にも それはお釈迦様のある特権なんです
語れるっていうこと 通じるように語れると
そういう釈尊のはできないというんだから
それぐらい苦しいんだと
これでお釈迦様がそういうたとえを持ってくるんですよ
で  これはまあ一応口で言います
で ある犯罪者を捕まる
捕まって王様のところに持って
お釈迦様に王様日本です
王様 この極悪人だと 王様はやりたいことをやってください
罰を与えてください すると王様がでは朝
この人に槍で回刺してくださいとって言う
それでもう槍で回刺す
で 昼になったら王様があの人はまだ生きてるんですか？生きてるんだよと
では昼も回刺してくださいと
それで午後になったらどうですかと
あの犯人はまだ生きてる
あ そう ではまた回刺してくださいと
それで 1 日で槍で回刺すんです
でお釈迦様は比丘たちに聞くんです
どうですかね あの 苦しいでしょうかねと
お釈迦様こう聞いたら
比丘たちは何をおっしゃるんでしょうかと
一回刺しても刺されても
もう人間には耐えられません
ですから どんな槍か分かりません
見たこともないしね 当時でこの人を罰を与える時の使う槍でしょう
それはものすごい苦しくなるように
戦争で人を殺すためだったら
もう鋭くてサッと死んだ方が勝ちでしょうね
その時はそんな痛みは感じない
これは罰だからね 痛めてあげないと
だからそんな感じの槍でしょう
だから比丘たちはよくわかってます
当時の人々は一回刺されても刺しても
人間にはもう忍耐できんと
これ回と回というと 一日はもう話にならんというんです
はい 次取ってみて 次にお釈迦様がこの手で取れるぐらい小さな石一個を取るんですよ
石一個取って 比丘たち
この石とこのヒマラヤはどちらが多いんですかと
大きいんですかと 言うと
ヒマラヤっていやもうもう世界一でしょうに
大きさは そんな比較できんと
お釈迦様のお手に取っているこの石一個とは
それで完結します あの人が受ける苦しみと地獄の苦しみもそんなもんやと
石一個と同じですよ 人が受ける回槍で刺されて受ける苦しみが
地獄に送る受ける苦しみっていうのは
ヒマラヤぐらいもう話にならんほど大きいんだよと
で そういうお話がバーラパンディタスッタにあるんです
だからたとえでしか説明できないという
それから地獄に行ったらどうなるのかという順番があるんです
地獄のこのニレパーラと地獄の職人たちがいるんですね
まず鉄の槍で槍本を両手
両足 胸に刺すと それもう地獄の中だからね
もう槍も全部燃えているんです
はい 次 これすっごく短くしたんで説明は
次に斧で削って調整するんです
槍で刺して止まってもらって
みんなこの研究も実験とか言って
カエルさん人やってるでしょうに
それから削るんです 斧で
はい 次 それから逆さにするんです
逆なして また何で刺すか
それ剃りカミソリで剃るんですね
もうずっと もういわゆるもっと鋭いもので剃るんですね
それイトシス言うんですよ
この本刺 本刺しても この生命は死なないんだよと
もう極端な苦しみを味わうんだけど
業がある限りは死なないんだと
そこで斧でもう調整する時でも
いい形にするでしょう
それでも死なないんだと
業があるんだから 次にまたもう微妙な調整するんですね
カミソリで剃って もう切って切って
いわゆるカンナみたいなもんですね
カンナかけてもなかなか死なないんだと
はい 次 次に車につないで燃えている道路で引いたり押したりする
もうさらに調整するんですよ
道路っていうのは溶岩みたいでサーッと燃えている
そんなのは我々にわかりやすく言ってる
もうイメージであって
実際 地獄はそんなもんじゃないんです
だから我々がイメージするためには
まあ溶岩でもできている
もう道路があって そこで車でこの人々はもう引ったり
また押したり いろいろもう削るんですね
いわゆる まあわかりやすくいうと
まあ神 あのサンドペーパーやるような感じでサンドペーパーかけるんですね
はい 次 それでも死なないんだと
それから燃えている炭の山を登らされたり
下ろされたりする ものすごい熱く燃えている炭があって
山 これ登らせるんです
で また下ろされる また登ると
そういうことをさせるんだと
でも死にませんと 一回経典に例えがあります
なんか誰かが地獄に落ちちゃって
それですごい苦しいんだと行ったら
お釈迦様にまた比丘たちはどうしてぐらい苦しいんだと聞いたら
いや これは言えませんよと
たとえで言ってくださいませんかと言ったら
比丘たちにこの大量にこの生に
なんか台風とかあって
木がたくさん落ちてきたんですよ
まだまだ乾いてない もう干して生のまんまで
これは全部揃って 1箇所に集めてくださいと
言うとお坊さんたちはもうもうもう倒れたばっかりの枝
あっちこっち持ってきて
すっごい大きなもうたくさんお坊さんっているんだから
100人とかね もう簡単なことで大量に名作ったんだと
それでそれではお釈迦様
では地獄の火をね あの炭のね
ほんの一欠片持ってきますよと
ほんの一欠片 でお釈迦様の能力でそっと一欠片を持って入れたんです
すぐに上げてきたんです
すいた途端 全部さっと消えちゃって
灰になったと あの木は全部
それっていうのはほんの一欠片だよと
ということで だから地獄は怖いと
はい 次 次に次に この足から釜に入れるんですよ
これは特別な名前の釜です
ロウハクンビという まあ我々に分かりやすく言えば
なんか溶岩ある釜だと思ってください
そこにも足からポーンと入れて
もう茹でるんだそうです
泡立てただけな でも死なないんだと
極端に苦しみを味わうだけで
まだ自由意志もない はい
次 それから大地獄に放り込む
大地獄はもっとひどいんです
だから各地獄の苦しみはそれぞれ違うし
もう説明いろいろあるんですけどね
仏典ではなかなかそんなに出てこないんですからね
まあそんなもんですね
地獄は それは仏典 お釈迦様の経典からのところで
はい 次に行きます 何をされても悪行が消えるまで死なないのです
はい それからちょっとした皆様疑うかもしれません
いくらなんでも槍で刺しちゃうと
イエス様みたいにね もう死ぬでしょうと
これが肉体で考えるんだからそう思っちゃうんですよ
私たちの心と動物の心は肉体に依存しているんですよ
だから肉体が潰れると
心が別なところに行くんですね
人間 動物以外は肉体に依存しないんです
体があるんだけど 体が心が作るんですよ
それで私たちは天界にいるんだから
受ける苦しみにはリミットがあるんですよ
そういうことで こういう地獄なんかね
人々に生命が肉 肉 肉体じゃなくて体があるんだけど
そういう程度なんだから
完全に潰して壊れないという
それから痛みって何なのか知ってますかね
痛みは心ですよ 肉体じゃないんです
だから我々今肉体やと思ってる
もう本当は肉体ですよ
人間だから だから我々得る楽しみも苦しみも
肉体を通していかなくちゃいけないんですよ
だから簡単に超えられる肉体だから
どうした苦しみも味わえないし
もうもうどうした楽しみも味わえないんですよ
楽しいと思っているんだけど
ろくな楽しみを感じてないんです
だからお釈迦様は瞑想して体から離れてくださいと
極端な無限に幸福を感じますよと
体から離れちゃうと 心をね
もう感じたい放題感じるんですね
人間が体から心を離れることは善行為で
極端に幸福感じるんです
逆はできません 人間の極端に苦しみ感じることはできないんです
次元が違う それにはアッパーにいかなくちゃいけないんです
だから これが物語っぽくて
人間にわかりやすくして説明できないと言ってお釈迦様が人間のイメージを作って説明するんです
で そうしちゃうと なんか理屈を語る人なんか
これこれもうもう釜で茹でると生きてるわけないでしょ
それは人間だったらね
そちらの体はそういう体じゃないんです
ずっと業が もうだから極端な苦しみっていうものは
人間にはいくらなんでも想像できませんということなんです
たとえ溶岩の話を持ってきたっても
地獄はこの地球の中にあるという感じがあるのはそういうわけなんですよ
人間に想像できるのは
一番熱い 一番危ないところはもう地球の中の溶岩ですからね
マグマですからね まあそこで考えてるみたいですけどね
実際わからない どこにあるのかっていうことは
はい 心は絶えず連続するので
悪が消えるまでその寿命が続くんですね
だから自由意志がないんだから
もうあのパターンで思考を持っていかなくちゃいけない
だから地獄にいる生命に何か面白いことを見せたっても
それは認識できん それ自由はないんです
うーん だから困るでしょうね
あの阿弥陀様とかね 地獄からなんとか解放してあげようと思ってもできません
お釈迦様にさえも もうこれはできませんということになるんだからね
次に行きます それから地獄の寿命について
それまた経典ですよ コーカリカという比丘がサーリプッタ尊者を冒涜したので
たちまちパドマという地獄に落ちたのです
これはいろんな経典にあるんですよ
これはかなり仏教 ブッダの時代で話題になった話なんです
これ デーヴァダッタのグループでもないんですよ
中作であるバラモン人で
まあ自分の親戚が作ったお寺で生活していたんだと
でもあまりバラモン人が相手にしなかったと
だから自分の人でしょうし
自分が作ったお寺の人ですし
まあそれなりの何かご飯をあげたりして
托鉢に行ったらもう何かあげるぐらいで
もうあまり相手にしない
この人はもう大胆に尊敬してほしいんですよ
それでサーリプッタ尊者がいろんなところに歩くんだから
そのお寺にも行ったんです
そちらに行ったのは あのちょこっと隠れてたかったんです
お釈迦様に毎日仕事を与えられるわ
もうね すごいたくさん
子供たちはみんなサーリプッタ尊者のところにいるわ
それでお坊さんたちのもうすごい難しい問題
何か出てくると 仏教の真理ですね
それをずっと説明していく
もう忙しくてもちょっと一人になりたいということで
誰にも言わないで さっとそのあまり人が行かない
あまりお布施ももらわない
あのお寺に行ったんです
そしたらコーカリカ比丘は見たら
これもうなんでもないんですよ
天皇陛下が来たみたいな
もうサーリプッタ尊者でしょ
で サーリプッタ尊者が私がいることは誰にも言わないでくださいと
ではなくて もう誰にも言わなくてもいいんだと
ちょこっと休ませてくださいと
もうサーリプッタ尊者もコーカリカ比丘も次の日は何のことなく托鉢に行って
ちょこっとご飯もらって
それ召し上がって で このコーカリカ比丘がやっぱり自慢したいんですよ
自分のちっぽけなお寺に
信者さんも自分の親戚たちなんですけど
全然相手にしてくれないんだけど
捨てたもんじゃないんだと
自分もサーリプッタ尊者さえも個人的にちょこっと休みたければ私のところに来るんだよと
いうことで やっぱりもう自分の親戚に行っちゃったんです
あんた方知ってますか？今日二人托鉢したでしょ
あのお坊さん 誰か知ってますかと
知らないの あれがあの偉大なるサーリプッタ尊者だよと
お釈迦様の次 2番目ですよと
お前ら何も知らないバカたちやとちょっと怒った
親戚だから怒ったってもね
そんな質素に扱ってね
よくいいと思っているところだよと
こちらの心の中で考え方があったんですよ
サーリプッタ尊者も信者さんはどうしても仏教の方々だから
ものすごくもうお布施したりするでしょうと
でもこのサーリプッタ尊者は全く欲はないものに執着はしないし
もう極端に質素な生活をしているし
だからもうお寺にもらったお布施っていうのは持っていくはずは丸っきりない
それは絶対ありえないんです
もうあの性格 みんな知ってるんだからね
そうすると まあお寺にいくらかお布施入るでしょうと言ったくらいもあったんです
思った通りに信者さんたちがいろいろ衣を作って持ってくるは
あれこれと もうあるだけの無理までして
サーリプッタ尊者にじきじきお布施できるということで
もう徹底的にお布施しちゃったんですね
そこでサーリプッタ尊者はそれを受けて
まあ信者さんに説法もして
まあしょうがない もうバレたんだからね
そうすると まあ智慧の第一人者らしく
みんなにちゃんとアドバイスして説法して
まあ徳を移行してそのまま帰っちゃったんです
休むことはしなかったんです
これには この人に腹が立ったんですよ
なんで言わないでサクッと帰るんでしょうかと
もうちょっと行った方が良かったのにとかね
自分の欲が出てきたんですね
それで怒りになっちゃったんですよ
そこでお布施を全部サーリプッタ尊者にということにくれたんだから
サーリプッタ尊者は普通ならでは
まあ私に入りませんだから
じゃあお寺に使ってくださいと一言は言わなくちゃいけないでしょうにと
どこかでもうこの戒律的なところも微妙で
そのお坊さんもいくらなんでもその一言葉も言ってくれてないし
で 一言葉言ったら自分もいただいたものになるでしょ
その一言葉をサーリプッタ尊者があえて言わなかったんです
なぜかというと これはこの人は強引に人に言って
頼んで 人に強引にお布施させたんだと
だから人の徳に邪魔してはいけないんだけど
一応受けたんですけど
これはもう私も使うわけにはいきませんし
こいつにももう使うわけにはいきませんと
これはもう強引に取ったものやと
いくら  返り討ちを犯してはないんですけど
だからちょっと戒めてやるぞってことでもあるし
そのまま言ったんですね
戒められるどころか はい
人を自分にいらないものは人がもらうことにも嫉妬するんではないかと
サーリプッタ尊者にいらないってことをよく知ってるんですね
だったら人に与え与えるものの常識でしょうと
でもなんでって やっぱり嫉妬深いんだと
我慢できなくてお釈迦様に言ったんですね
サーリプッタ尊者はまあそういうほどはないんだと
言うほどの人格者じゃないんだと
拙相な生活してるかもしれませんだけど
やっぱりもうまあ嫉妬深いんじゃないかなとかね
それでお釈迦様何を言うんでしょうか
すっごいもう反対したんです
それで偉大なる方にそんなことを言って思ってはいけないと
でもこれ比丘たちも聞いてね
もうとんでもないことを
あなたは これとんでもないと
比丘たちもやめさせようと思うんですよ
お釈迦様やめさせようと思ったんです
それは偉大なる方やと
人間の父親やと お釈迦様は我々お釈迦様に人間父親って言うんですけど
お釈迦様はサーリプッタ尊者にそう言うんですよ
あんた方の父親の偉大だと
お釈迦様の大のお気に入りっていうことは私はよくわかってますよと
サーリプッタ尊者は だからお釈迦様にすごい気に入りだから
お釈迦様はそういうのを僕はよくわかりますよと
無実こそならんと しかし
サーリプッタ尊者はやっぱりパーピッチャーのお坊さん方っていう
パーリ語で言えばね やっぱり欲があるんだと
回も断ってもこれはもう聞かない
頑固 そのまま自分のところに帰ったんで
帰ったら体からその場でもできものがずっと現れてきて
苦しくなっちゃったんです
ただ この人の過去世で修行した時のこのある梵天梵天の神がいて
この梵天の神が不還果に悟ってますよ
だからその次元ではみんな仏教徒でも悟ってるんだからね
悟ってる神々 梵天 そこからある神がわざと来たんですよ
この人のこと心配して
して もうもう苦しんで
まあもうもう死にかけてるし
だから朦朧としているんだから
神々にも連絡できるし
梵天の神様がね 呼んで
梵天の神々は坊さんであるとあまり敬語は使わない名前でも比丘やと
向こうは年上偉いんだからね
で こう返ってきたのはすぐ懺悔しなさいよと
お前 即懺悔しなさいよと
なんてこと言ってるんですけど
あんた誰？と言う 私はもうなんとかなんとか
名前の梵天ですと ああ
ああ そう 私はお釈迦様に聞いたんですけど
あなたはね 不還果になって
二度とこの世に戻らない人だとお釈迦様おっしゃってるんですけど
不還果っていうのはもうまた戻らない
二度と戻らない人とお釈迦様に聞いたことがあるんだけどと
あの梵天の偉大なる聖者でしょうに
またもう断ったんです
梵天はもうまあ それはそうなんですけど
あなたのこと心配して来たんだと
サーリプッタ尊者に懺悔しなさいと
謝りなさいと 謝ったら罪はチャラになるんですけどね
謝れなかったんです で
梵天は帰ったんですけど
お釈迦様に報告して 私もやってみたんだけどと
だから頑張ったんだよ
地獄に落ちないようにと
でもたちまちあの出来物が出て腫れて
もうそのまま死んじゃって
地獄にカチンといったんです
1日足らずで それパドマという地獄なんですね
この地獄の寿命を聞かれたところで
釈尊は想像できないほど長いと答えられたのですが
どうにかたとえ話を使ってでも教えていただけるようにと
もうまた頼まれましたです
比丘たちも比丘たちで
お釈迦様これ私もできないと言ったっても
まあ頼むんですね  仏教の世界はまあそういう世界なんですよね
質問する ものすごい上明るいんですね
はい 次に行きます それで地獄の寿命について
注釈書も参考にして そのたとえを説明します
マガダ国の八四つはコッサラ国の八一つ
これ大きさでちょっと数学になりますけどね
マガダ国の八もこの注釈書をいろいろ調べると
注釈書はスリランカでパーリ語にしたもんだから
ちょっとスリランカのものも入ってはいるんです
で かなり大きいんだと
マガダ八はおそらく まあこれから私の推測で言うんですけど
米を測る場合は 1合  2合ということで測る
1合というのは一人の分でしょ
ご飯になっちゃうと あれの三十ぐらいですね
三十二 マクダハチは米だったら三十二合入ります
これ定かじゃない これ私の勝手な注釈の説明は勝手にもう昔の単語だからもうわかりもわからない
それで小皿の鉢は一つ
四倍大きい 小皿八四倍はアーラカ一と呼ぶんです
アーラカ四つは一ドーナと呼ぶんです
四ドーナは一マーニカなんです
四マーニカは一カーリなんです
もうよく考えられますかね
米で見ると結構でしょ
三十二合掛ける八小皿一でしょうに
それから四四四四かけていくんですよ
そこでカーリ二十のゴマは車一台分
荷車って牛とか馬とか車一台分は一応入ります
これはゴマなんです 米じゃないんです
ゴマではなくゴマなんです
そこで注釈さらにこの小皿国のゴマはすごく小さいんだと
大きなゴマじゃないね
日本でもすごい高いゴマ一周ありますね
かなり粒が大きいものではなくて
すごい粒が小さいんだと
一万年に一個で そのゴマを捨てても終わるのは早いと
二十回りのゴマを一個ずつ
一万年に一個取る また一年経ったら一個取る
それで早く終わりますよと
しかし アッブダ地獄の寿命はもっと長いんだよと
アッブダという地獄 これでもう数学はもう飛んじゃうでしょ
だからこのただ無限無量というのをお釈迦様は何の理論的に使っているわけじゃないんですよ
それなりにも計算で使っているんです
次に行きます それからアッブダ二十回ですよ
一ニラッブダの地獄は寿命は二十ニラブダ二十回アバボウという地獄が長いんです
アバボウという地獄の二十回寿命長いんですよ
アタタという地獄は アタタという地獄
二十回長いんですよ アハハという地獄は
アハホという地獄は二十回は一クムダ地獄の寿命なんです
クムダ地獄の二十回長いんでソウガンディカというのは
ソウガンディカ地獄二十回はウッパタ地獄は長いんです
できれば計算してください
何年かと 人間の数字はもう
飛ぶ もうどうせ はい 次に行きます
ウッパラ二十回は一プンダリーカ地獄なんですよ
二十プンダリーカ地獄は一パドマ地獄なんです
そのパドマに行った コーカーリキ比丘はサーリプッタ尊者に怒りを抱いてパドマ地獄に落ちたのであると
一旦落ちたら自由意識はなくなりますから
その寿命はいなくちゃいけないんです
だから想像できないでしょ
一応 注釈書は これらは地獄の名前ではなく
地獄の寿命の長さを示す数字だと言ってます
プンダリーカ地獄 パドマ地獄はないんだと
それは寿命で数字で寿命で言ってるんだよと
落ちたのは本当はアジビ地獄やと
それはまあ注釈書を信じるか
お釈迦様を信じるか どちらかということで
これはサンユッタニカーヤの一の四九ページで
アングッッターニカーヤ五の一六九でスッタニパータマハーヴァコーカーリキスッタという経典もあります
いろんなところである経典です
だからかなり話題になっていた話なんです
これも計算も全部お釈迦様がおっしゃったものです
頼まれて はい